welcome back to Las Vegas now it's time
to talk golf food music and wine because
those are all things that you can
experience at the Audi Henderson Lake
Las Vegas classic and here to tell us
more about this upcoming event we have
John openshaw and Brendan virgin from
reflection Bay thank you guys so much
for being here thanks for having us so
you're going to put my golf skills to
the test in a minute here but first we
got to talk about this event happening
Friday and Saturday October 7th and 8th
tell us a little bit about what we can
expect and if people want to get
involved how they do that sure it's a
great event we do it every year and
every year it gets bigger and bigger on
Friday the 7th uh we have a double
shotgun going out uh it's an opportunity
for people to go out enjoy reflection
Bay have a great time on the golf course
we've got some games and prizes and
things there's still some foursomes that
are available they'll start at sixteen
hundred dollars a piece okay
information's at lakelasvegasclassic.com
well we're seeing some photos here I
love reflection Bay I feel like I'm on
vacation anytime I go out to Lake Las
Vegas and it's really fun you're also
bringing in some local chefs and tell us
a little bit about the the food and
drink and the party aspect of it yeah so
Saturday night is the big event right I
mean we have uh it's a great time where
we bring together the best chefs the
best bartenders great music all
throughout town on Friday excuse me
Saturday night from 5 30 to 8 30. uh
they're out there it's a great time to
be able to
try out some of these we got 12
award-winning chefs wow and you can try
out some of their sample dishes some of
the most popular things we've got
mixologists from all around town their
signature dishes and uh great music so
you can come out and dance and it's a
great setting right there on Lake Las
Vegas at reflection Bay yeah well that
sounds like it's the place to be October
7th and 8th and we were joking earlier
but I I'm not making this up I've never
golfed a day in my life my extent of
skills goes to like the glow-in-the-dark
mini golf here in Las Vegas
can you guide me through and you know if
people are attending this event they're
probably practicing so what do we do we
have the hpgi Institute over at Lake Las
Vegas that's where myself and Craig
Barlow Jeff Gallagher we all work
together they people don't enjoy golf
more um it's one of those things like
you we take people from who've just
tried it to all the way people who are
aspiring college players and even people
are playing out on tour to get to that
so you know what let's give it a go
let's give it a go what's the worst
we're gonna happen this year so I mean
if you come out here we've got this one
set up so you decide right-handed so
where is the right hand the left hand is
going to go on the top of the club okay
and the right hand is going to move so
let's just set the putter down okay now
you're trying to bend over a little too
much
there we go that's it you're gonna let
the putter do the work now just swing it
back and swing it through okay you guys
I'm nervous here we go you can't do
anything I'm not responsible oh okay
that was probably just a little too hard
okay okay we're getting there a little
softer not you know what we have
different Putters so John's going to
give you a different one to try that
might work a little easier okay let's
try one more time here we go
a little bit too hot
okay here but I'm gonna switch over here
and really quickly just one more time as
I'm doing my final swing here where and
when how can people get involved with
the classic Foundation it's online the
Lake Las Vegas classic.com golf's Friday
on the 7th main event is Saturday the
8th it's great time come on that sounds
fun okay terrible
no one saw that thank you guys it rolled
off the set oh my gosh well check this
out uh you can do better next time
Julian